scènes de liesse à la sortie de l'hôtel
ibis des batignolles mais pour cause
c'est la fin d'une lutte de près de deux
ans pour ces femmes de chambre qui
viennent tout juste de signer un accord
avec l'hôtelier
après huit mois de grève et 14
d'activité partielle de cette pas facile
mais dieu merci on a gagné on a du temps
des repas victoire on n'avait pas à la
victoire jusqu'à trouver les victoires
ça c'est bien
on a bâti on a gagné on est très content
en juillet 2010 9 34 femmes de chambre
sur 40 que compte l'hôtel avait entamé
une grève puis saisi les prud'hommes
employé par la société stn sous
traitants du nettoyage elle dénonce l
inégalité de traitement entre elles et
les salariés de l'hôtel ibis notamment
en termes de rémunération et de
conditions de travail une grande
victoire
une très belle victoire et c'est une
histoire pour nous qui va rester à vide
en voilà dans notre vie c'est nous quand
même au les femmes rasées qui faisons ce
métier et on a on ne mérite pas ça on ne
mirent pas de telma traitance dans leur
établissement et il faut quoi aussi les
autres collègues aussi n'ai pas peur il
faut que plein de courage de suivre
notre exemple sorti et de noces est
passé à beaucoup a dénoncé dans les
hôtels l'accord signé par la cgt hpe la
foncière immobilière d'accord accord une
veste ou encore rester en groupe prévoit
en plus une augmentation de salaire de
250 à 500 euros brut par mois
la baisse du nombre indicative de
chambre a nettoyé par heure un combat
sans relâche porté par la cgt hpe dont
les représentants étaient émus aux
larmes à la sortie de la rencontre
une avancée significative pour claude
davy animateurs syndical cgt hpe qui
voit là une victoire historique
ce n'est pas gagné d'avancé puisque dès
le début de cette grève on a dit aux
salariés attention on s'attaque au big
up au groupe accor qui est très très
difficile dans la dans la négociation
quand on a des conflits du travail donc
par tpr et prévoyez de partir pour une
grève longue et dure on a été caché
et les filles l'ont bien compris et
effectivement on arrive après 22 mois de
lutte à un succès avec cette victoire
incroyable que pour ma part j'ai jamais
vu dans ma carrière syndicale
l'ibis de clichy-batignolles deuxième
plus grand hôtel ibis de france avec
plus de 700 chambres est devenu par ce
combat le plus important jamais mené par
la cgt hpe le symbole des conditions de
travail dégradées des femmes de chambre
avec cette victoire ces femmes
souhaitent donné l'envi à toutes les
femmes de chambre de se battre pour plus
de reconnaissance et de justice sociale